without question the iPad Mini 6 has
been the best iPad you can buy for iPad
things and it's about to get even better
with the iPad Mini 7 which I believe is
coming as soon as next month and I'll
explain my reasoning in this video but
first I've got to go through five new
changes you should expect the first and
most obvious Change is Gonna Be the
upgrade to a new chip to boost
performance even further for the latest
and greatest games and apps yes the iPad
Mini 6 is already killer for many of the
highest end games out there like Call of
Duty genshin impact League of Legends
and more but the extra performance will
mean that you can get perfectly solid 60
FPS gameplay with maxed out settings
while using less of the Chip's power
which means cooler temperatures now as
far as which chip the iPad Mini 7 will
get it's either going to be the a16 or
the upcoming a 70 teen which is built on
tsmc's new three nanometer chip
technology now one reason for doubting
the a17 is because the chip yield is
fairly low for these new three nanometer
chips so Apple might want to focus it on
the iPhone 15 Pro Models at first but
then again the sales volume for iPad
Minis isn't that high anyway because the
sales for the iPads have been even lower
especially with Apple's latest earnings
revealing that their iPads are not
selling that well right now and it's
probably going to be the same for the
next quarter so even if they give it the
a17 it might not be that big of an issue
in terms of low chip yield and then on
top of that we have one more excellent
reason for Apple to give it the a17 chip
when the iPad Mini 6 came out in 2021
Apple gave it the same a15 chip as the
brand new iPhone 13c series that
launched at the same time so I'm pretty
sure they're going to do the same thing
this year with the iPad Mini 7 in an
attempt to get people to upgrade
assuming it does come this year and if
it doesn't end up coming this year and
somehow gets delayed until next year it
for sure will have the a17 chip now
alongside General app and gaming
benefits the extra performance will also
make the new mini more capable for a
performance related work like editing
videos especially since the newer a17
chip is expected to have a brand new
redesigned GPU potentially with Hardware
Ray tracing support and of course newer
encoders and now let's move on to change
number two which is battery life with
that new a17 chip we should expect that
the battery life should get better
because once again we're going to be
seeing a huge leap between the current 5
nanometer a15 chip technology apology to
the brand new three nanometer Tech in
the a17 which basically means that the
transistor density is basically more
densely packed in so that we're going to
be getting more performance per watt
with using less battery life and staying
cooler now as far as whether Apple will
be putting in better battery technology
or larger physical batteries it's hard
to tell because the size of the mini is
already so limited but it should help
improve everyday battery life regardless
with that new chip and now moving on to
change number three apple is hopefully
gonna fix the display refresh rate
issues that happen with the current iPad
Mini 6 that has been causing jelly
scrolling issues lots of reviewers have
been pointing that out and it was
actually one of the biggest reasons some
people chose not to upgrade to the mini
6 and choose other iPads instead because
that has been annoying quite a few
people but me personally I don't really
think it's that big of a deal but
hopefully Apple does put some attention
towards that and hopefully they fix it
this time around and honestly even with
the Jelly scrolling issues everything
else was just so good for reviewers
especially with that new smaller more
compact size with the redesign with USBC
the apple pencil 2 support with wireless
charging and more it's just been so good
but in terms of the display Tech what if
Apple takes it a step further and what
if they finally add 120 hertz Pro motion
support that would be incredible well
most likely not because that's a huge
reason why people buy the iPad Pro but I
do expect Apple to eventually bring the
120 hertz feature to the lower end iPad
Air and then the iPad Mini especially if
the upgrade promotion on the iPad Pros
to go even higher like 240 hertz which
was actually rumored in the past back in
February of 2021 Apple actually won a
patent that would bring variable refresh
rates up to 180 to 240 hertz so Apple
can easily introduce those upgrades on
the iPad Pro Models first and then give
regular 120 hertz to the lower end iPads
and now getting into change number four
we should definitely be expecting some
camera upgrades both on the front and on
the back as far as the front we should
definitely be getting the new
horizontally placed landscape selfie
camera with the center stage feature
because Apple is very likely to bring
that feature and the landscape mode to
the entire iPad lineup especially since
they decided to give it to the budget
iPad first so it makes sense to have it
across the entire lineup to kind of
support that new look and feature
because it looks a lot better for
Facetime video and then as far as the
rear they're likely going to add things
like prores video audio Zoom stereo
audio recording probably portrait mode
and portrait lighting support and other
new camera upgrades and now finishing
off with change number five before I get
into the release date discussions we're
likely to of course get updated Wi-Fi
specs for example getting the latest
Wi-Fi 6E and probably Bluetooth 5.3 and
then on top of that we could expect some
new small features like maybe the apple
pencil hover feature that the iPad Pro
just got and maybe some other pencil
related upgrades or small upgrades in
other areas like for example probably a
newer 5G modem that's going to be more
efficient for these lower end iPad
models and now let's get into the
release date discussion and why I think
it could come as soon as next month
recently Mark German said that we could
get minor spec bumps of the regular iPad
iPad Air and iPad Mini later this year
and then on top of that shrimp Apple Pro
just said that apple is working on the
iPad Mini 7 and it could launch as soon
as this year however we do also have
munchie quo who believes that mass
production of the mini 7 will begin in
the first quarter of 2024 but here's the
issue I have with that the new iPad Pro
Models are actually rumored to be coming
in the spring of 2024 which is exactly a
year and a half after the recent iPad
Pro so those go in cycles of around 1.5
years so it perfectly lines up to the
spring and those iPad models are going
to be a massive massive upgrade so apple
is gonna want all of the attention on
the iPad Pro only during the spring
apple usually upgrades the iPad Pros on
a different timeline than the rest of
the iPad lineup so that the pros get the
most attention and since they're coming
in the spring of next year the fall is
the perfect time to upgrade both the
iPad Air and the iPad mini and why well
because Apple has been updating the air
every one and a half years with the last
two updates on a different cycle than
the iPad Pros so it makes us to do it
again this fall since it'll be exactly a
year and a half after the iPad Air 5's
release also the iPad Pros coming next
spring are expected to come with a brand
new OLED display technology so if the
spec bump iPad Air 6 and mini 7 are
coming without OLED displays it'll make
sense to get these updates out now
because I'm fairly certain every iPad
except for the budget model will get
upgraded to OLED as well right after the
OLED iPad Pros are gonna get released we
already recently got a leak that Apple
was planning to reduce iPad bezel sizes
just like they're doing for the iPhone
15 Pro Models and I think that will
begin with the new OLED display models
coming later on on top of that we're
expecting the M3 chip to get released as
soon as October with the first M3 Max
but the issue is that the iPad Air 6 is
expected to get the M2 Chip so it needs
to get updated before the M3 gets
revealed 22 September as the perfect
release date and we do also know that in
2019 Apple released both the iPad Mini 5
and the iPad Air 3 at the same time so
what if they're planning on doing it
again this September I think it makes
total sense and matches all of the leaks
that we're having right now so there you
guys go those were five new changes in
my thoughts on the release date for the
iPad Mini 7. hopefully you enjoy this
video and if you did let me know down in
the comment section below and subscribe
up there and definitely check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
foreign